I don't know just cuz they're
vegetables or cuz they're psychedelics
I'm the wrong person to
ask I'm finding out with
you this show is brought to you by
tracker never lose anything again with
tracker listeners to this show the
Church of What's Happening Now get a
special discount of 30% off of your
entire order that's right 30% off of
your entire order just go to th
tracker.com th H tracker.com and enter
promo code church that's right that's
the tracker.com th tracker.com and enter
promo code Church to get 30% off of your
entire order and the show is brought to
you by Helix
sleep Helix sleep allows you to get a
custom mattress online for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands go to
helixsleep.com
joeey I'm doing good can you guys
believe what I like this is the best
I've ever done I'm real happy go to
helixsleep.com Joey and get $50 off of
your order that's helix.com
you you're reading like the
smartest brother in junior
high I was always really excited to read
go to helixsleep.com Joey to get $50 off
your order that's helixsleep.com
Joey and go to on it.com and use code
word church to get 10% off all of the
great optimization products like Alpha
Brain and new mood damn I think I got
Alpha Brain right now bro you better put
a track on your D le sayat you
losing Crown
player oh
oh you have no idea
what cave you walked
into it's the Church of What's Happening
Now kick that
muie
reefa
mushrooms
edibles
laughter
laughter get your together
Wednesday May
25th you are here the day the devil was
buried raped given a Cosby pill and
in the
ass what's happening gentlemen Amen
brother it's that type of party tonight
see oon in the house we putting the
devil to sleep Lee sayat with his little
blue shirt on tonight beautiful we've
got Lee in training he himself
last week why did I how that me me
me me and my girlfriend we at like four
stars go Lee you're in training yeah you
cannot go backwards when I'm out of town
yeah so he up for two nights I
had to kick up the milligrams and bring
in mushrooms and hash and just
for the record he's up tonight what he's
saying is is that on Saturday is when to
take 500 500 you're in train I get this
is punishment you're you got to go up to
8900 because all week we're flying with
8900 you're letting your
to that's okay that's all right son
that's when you're an astronaut dude
star one they don't give a they
just want us to keep eating
stars I'm never going to stop eating
Stars they delous they're delicious
they're delicious nutritious and they
take you for the psychological
ride of your life theovon what is it
baby I'm here man I'm freaking here dude
I'm trying to keep the devil out of my
system bro but he's here those mushrooms
are qu I'm feeling positive
dude ate me a little stem I'm right I
think I may might need another brother
just to get Daddy you know just to get
the devil off my neck son little
ones with the little there you go huh
something this little torch little one
Le this little baton huh put this little
black one Lee Le that's the longest one
that's the longest one in the bag
brother that was the main one under the
I'm not even we breaking that one
in half no you give me the worst half I
eat the other half well you give a
look at cheers bro yeah cheers
fcking come on Lee get your brain up man
you already oh Jesus Le looks
that look like your your head is holding
blood bro your head's holding extra
blood from your body bro that mushroom
tastes terrible with this in it I
let it sit in my gum for a minute Jesus
Christ we're going to see some siloc
cybin the church what happen now
you never know what's going to happen we
might eat a mushroom we might
eat acid we might just do an edible we
might be ourselves you know what I'm
saying might e ass bro and we might eat
listen all avenues are open on a
Wednesday night you should leave your
Avenues open I've been telling
for years I'll tell you
what happened today I had to go to
Hollywood at 4:30 to do AR thing I had
to do the beginning of it cuz I didn't
do it yesterday at least I you going to
like this one the what's happening now
yeah so I get off the uh 101 I
first of I see two Ex two accidents on
the 101 back to back Le light day light
day two dumb right in
front of me uh went to get into the same
Lane it was perfect they just went bam
and then this idiot kept going and hit
him I went right around that
oh you saw it happen I saw right
right beautiful and people like call the
police I ain't calling nobody it's got
nothing to do with Uncle Joey I got
to do with people to say I got to get
back in the HOV lane where is
always let them fight let them gun each
other down bro so then as I'm pulling
off another go straight I
mean this guy shoots into the
Lane of the people coming from like
Universal City off the Lancer and he
just shoots into that lane sideswipes
the
I just went around
him like did you beep as you go by like
I'm one of his I beeped at him though I
just
beep and they both looked at me like
what the I know you did you always
beep at him when you like wave I wave
both of me that's really messed up
you're beep you're beeping and then it's
like who the was they just look
at me like so I get off the
one I get off I exit lanasham
and I go north on lanasham and I make
the left on Magnolia and I'm
thirsty as I got 10 minutes to kill
before I got to pick up the baby so I go
to
7-Eleven as I walk into 7- it's bum day
today at 7-Eleven oh yeah it's
major league bum they got Brothers out
there out front one brother oh get first
of all get him dude every black
community you got to go to your local
7-Eleven that's somebody's dad that's
somebody's Uncle that's somebody every
any 7-Eleven there's a brother out there
right now now go get him and bring him
home there was one brother there was
three white dudes and there was a creepy
white dude in the corner oh that's the
worst that guy I come out and the simple
brother says hey man I'm having a rough
time can you spare some change on the
way very polite the three white guys are
like hey hey hey we need money can you
help us and the just sat
there talking to himself with his hand
like he was like one of those language
people I don't know what the he was
saying I go in I get the w water you
know what man I refrained from giving
those people money because I saw that
show where they stand on Laurel Canyon
uhhuh and then they drive to
their BMW they walk to the BMW
with you know $200 and quarters and
you know and I I had a
dollar bill I had 20s in the wallet but
I paid with an ATM I don't know what oh
no no I paid with I had $3 bills I
bought the one water mhm and I had the
$1 and I said you know what I'm going to
give it to the black dude okay he went
brother H he was by the door number one
he was polite right uh the three white
dudes were young yeah at that age I was
robbing I I refus to ask
somebody you know a dinner or something
yeah but not to stand in front of a
place three of them yeah not one
of them three of them three of them you
know that's not necessary three of you
guys pan handling okay how about one guy
pan handles and the other two go mug
somebody do something you got to do
something proactive go to that Diner
across the street after they can take
the garbage out do something no they
were like expecting people to give it to
them and the other guy was just half
I'm going to give him a dollar
to do what to go over to the park and
hit his his head with a tree a thousand
times so I just gave it to the black
guys I'm getting a car the three
white guys said to me started
saying racial really black dude got
up and said how about I like you three
white tremendous I just
saw two cat car accidents and now I'm
going to see one black dude go up
against three young white dudes the
three young white dudes backed up wow
three dudes backed up they
tapped out like Ted Cruz damn they said
it we ain't fighting three white
dudes three little 19yearold white dudes
damn against one black dude that was
homeless you know he hadn't had a meal
in like an hour oh he got nothing to
lose nothing to lose and the three and I
I sat in my car and I watched I told the
three dudes to go themselves and
they looked at me and the black guy
continue at him wow I just closed the
car open the window and listen to it and
the three white dud walked away he just
tuned in yeah what bro you never
get to see a good smackeroo no
oh not especially not on the not on the
west coast dude you never get to see you
see a shooting or you see a lot more
smacking smackaroos where you're from oh
down south I saw a brother take a bite
out of a Vietnamese guy once dude took a
b huge bite out of his arm bro
mea and everything bro ripped it right
out the Vietnamese guy was like threaten
him with all this karate and
everything and his brother the scrabs
were bit right into him dude
right you think about it that's the way
to do it that stops karate all the time
cuz I don't care what type of karate you
got they got no defense for the bite you
know what I'm saying nobody got well
what if a goes to bite you
oh my god hold on I got to call the main
ja and get these hold on let me
put my Komodo on dude and they bite your
ass dude and you remember that every
time you try to hug somebody and
if you got a little divot in it you know
you got a speed bump in your hug
why did I let Lee talk me into eat
mushrooms on a Wednesday night Le look
at your head look at Le open your eyes
bro I can't Dam dude what the
you're already up you gave me 800
before we're in training I told you when
you go down the when you join the
Marines they don't send you to Miami you
know with a seagull no they send
you to Paris Island de what
Marines did they put in Le my own
private Marin this the J what's
happening now though I love it bro we
got our own Marines they come in all
shapes sizes amen listen got a use in
the Marines when you you know no I don't
yeah we'll get three dudes to throw you
to that play glass window and
the guys in here you come flying through
with a helmet you know much damage you
could do yeah Lee Lee come out of it why
why you going to throw me as I was I'm
not sleeping I was just trying to
imagine being like a a human Bing yeah
but yeah you could do that we'll put
some shoulder pads on you and a
helmet with no t-shirt on you come
through that window no idea you thought
that black dude scared those three white
kids You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet with a
SWAT stick on your forehead with a beard
nobody's going to stop you a people will
put their guns up and go nah yeah nah
it's not even work this guy's got a SWAT
stick on his head with helmet and a
pair of shoulder pants he's
showing up like he's got bad intentions
yeah bro oh you should run for governor
in that outfit bro what's up Lee you
have a good time last night I had a
great time last night it was uh
it's fun like I've been the last few
times cuz we they've done I think they
did one or two seasons of digital and
then this is the third season of like TV
and it's just like the people I get to
like I got to hang out with Steve Simone
all night but then like I saw like Brian
rean was there which was cool and it big
J oers was there good time last night
show yeah last night a lot of people
just hanging out lot you know and who
else was there when uh Josh Adam Myers
had like six with him eating
uh uh you know set food yeah are
you going up no he's just there with six
eating set food they
combing his head he's like I just took
the bus over for dinner he don't give a
josham if it's a comedy central
event he's dead F my show got picked up
I don't give a I'm here to sing a
song I I saw uh Vince vaugh last night
at the uh Comedy Store too in par what
going on down there he was just hanging
out he went to him I guess him and Steve
Burn his buddies so he came out to hang
out with them and uh and then him
Sebastian Mancala were talking for a
long time but he was super cool I went
right up to him cuz I did his Wild West
Comedy Fest last year so I went right up
to him I was like vincey I don't
know
it V and he was super cool
like and then I was like I met your
sister last year at The Comedy Festival
and we talked for about 10 minutes he
was cool as hell man it uh Anyway said
that was just kind of cool with the
store but how uh I'm jealous I didn't
get to do the uh AR show man this is
Showcase for yeah did you showcase for
uhuh well what it's at the schore every
Tuesdays upstairs oh I didn't know that
just ask him why put me on a dog how
many stories you got you got more
stories than most people forget in their
life you know yeah man uh yeah
Feeling High I think I watch I
watched your special and it's my
favorite part about your special oh my
God is is just you're so goofy and it
just goes like it goes in ways like
that's my favorite part about Joey's
Comedy just sometimes when it goes ways
that you don't expect right cuz like
sometimes if you watch enough standup
comedy sometimes you can just guess the
punchline right and when you can't when
it's especially when it's so goofy was
it was great it was like cuz Joey and I
always talk whenever there's a new
special up we watch it we we discuss if
it's good and it yours is one of the
only few that's been you and Ali Wong
Ali Wong killed it too but thanks man I
appreciate that dude especially coming
from somebody that's seen so many
comedians and it works with joy man I
appreciate that well the funny thing is
that you do your joke what we like this
is what I like I think some sometimes
times that people have too much respect
for the punch line and it's not really
the punch line it's that little stupid
line you say afterward and listen right
now working today there ain't nobody
better than you saying that little
stupid line afterward because that line
that little stupid
line is a funnier thought that most
people get all day right and it's your
inner voice right I have the same inner
voice my inner voice cracks me up all
day what you think is funny so
bizarre and then you throw that last
little well you know and that that kills
it and people from the South do that
they have that last little three-word
sentence at the end of it that
just makes the whole joke you
know yeah well you inspire me man after
seeing you over at the store dude like
cuz you just like cuz you're sell like
it's not you're selling but like my
intention when I came out here was never
to sell jokes I wanted to be me and then
I I got caught up for a long time I just
everybody I thought like then then
nobody likes me I got to I got to fit in
just like everybody else but then I saw
you at the store one night dude and the
music went off I'm like what is
this going on dude I'm like are they
about to park a cruise ship on the
St around down there I you
got up and ripped everybody up
bunch of hamsters in
there when you left I was like I am
never not going to be myself again when
when you come out to Los Angeles and
you're here three months or you're here
two months and somebody's interested in
you and they take you to lunch and then
they sign you as a commercial agent or
theatrical agent or a manager doesn't
matter they're going to send you out for
an audition for most people don't know
that it could be any audition a
commercial audition and the first words
out of your mouth I don't give a if
you're classically trained is I don't
know what to do or you going to say
something and their response is going to
be be yourself and you're like thanks
yeah and you hear that guys for
15 years before one day you
go oh I know what they want now yeah I
wasn't getting it the whole time I'm
here I'm trying to be Doug stanh hope
I'm trying to be Paul Mooney you're
trying and I'm not saying I'm just
saying yeah I know you're not saying I
want to be brother I'm trying to be Nick
depalo I'm trying to be Mitch Hedberg
what if people go home and go what if I
could put Nick Theo and Mitch Hedberg
but the funniest character they're
hiding is the character they're hiding
yeah because that's the reason why they
came out here is because of that
character that's gotten them through
everything for 15 years that voice yeah
that voice that you only let out in
front of your friends yeah and that your
friends like that is hilarious
what're having a conversation at the
store one night you like last week some
guy got found with 30 pounds of hamster
bones you know they did in my town they
just busted a man it just doesn't
right away you got to stop what you're
doing in that conversation and giggle
because nine out of 10 people wouldn't
be proud that that happened in their
Hometown you know what I'm saying like
they wouldn't even mention it if
somebody comes up to me and go um are
you from New Orleans not really I'm from
Texas wait a second I got to go you know
you get to that point most
people would be embarrassed to say
something like that or it would take
them 10 minutes after everybody told
their story yeah to say oh by the way
there's a guy in no we were just talking
it's Tuesday night dud yeah we were
ready to go home and you came out with
it and I'm me and Lee were dying
in the car like what's he talking about
hamster meat what the is he talking
about and that's yeah they busted him
man listen they got him what if thank
God I like like it's like they got him
no I'm glad they got him dude 30 lb bag
of hamster one like I mean that's cuz
you have to there's not as much meat
there's very little bone in a hamster
brother and hamp's got a Hamp probably
has like a quar like an eighth of an
ounce in his chest plate bro you can't
even make a wish on their bones you know
there's nothing in there where do you
get all those hamsters from that's well
they breed them in our town I used to
work for this group they used to sell
tattooed hamsters and guinea pigs after
uh they tattoo them yeah they used to
Brand them with concerts and Raves they
would say it's tattoo just to make
people not be as sad about it but it was
a brand bro brand of what but like a
heat and ink bro for what like what did
it say uh 311 Green Day anything like a
different bands that were coming to town
toies swear to God bro to Acid Bath uh
who else Raves whatever bro we used to
truck these HS into the City and
vend them
bro we did man because there wasn't much
there wasn't much work in our town dude
you know you had to get what you could
get and they had a man that bred
hamsters and uh and then they had a do
the tattoos and they met up and
that was a merger that's big business
you know and they started uh a merger
they started doing it man I got me some
300 Mouse in my house and and some
other guy like you know what man I'm a
pretty good tattoo
artist that's Louisiana and that's it a
merger is fa that means someone
listening to this right now has had a
hamster with like a band label on it who
the buys a hamster listen if I went
to a concert think I'm bringing the
hamster home with ACDC no I'm
not no I'm not I'm going to be up
the whole night with this hamster in my
when you leave when you leave Coco when
you leave the place that's when we get
you bro you get it their people are
leaving on ecstasy pills they're on
Molly you leave you get that H
you get that warm little piece of God in
their hands they buy it every time bro I
was on the Rogan podcast and I told the
truth my main AFF trait if anybody ever
with you come to me don't say
nothing to them you come to me and you
go this guy with me and this this
this this and this and this way and I'll
ask you a bunch of questions and we'll
let we'll lay a road plan for you to
torture this guy bit slap him shoot him
just with him light his house on
fire you know steal his mail whatever
the and I first like I was when I
was a kid I really was the like if you
with me I just wait and Rob your
house I just Rob your house
that's it like you're getting your house
robbed that's it that's always the plan
and I'm taking the most important thing
to you that house if I would
steal eight ball cash jewelry but if I
knew they love their sneakers I'm taking
the sneakers too so when you see them
they're like man somebody busted into my
house and took my sneakers they took my
mother's jewelry you to steal their
spoons bro everything anything that I
knew would get them I'm a professional
torturer and when I got the boulder in '
87 I got the boulder in got the boulder
in uh December six yeah I was running
from cops and drug dealers I Ow like
60,000 in cash so you a boulder I was an
aspen I was an aspen causing
damage an as in 80 in 86 please please
you have no idea dog I was International
you
understand so I'm up and ASP I up
and the girl I'm with from Boulder we
had I had already a warrant in Boulder
and I'm like let's take a chance let's
move back to Boulder I got pulled over
no warrant but I got arrested for
reer doesn't really matter the
the the whole story is I got a job the
week before Denver gets beat up
by the Giants in the Super Bowl like
that Thursday I started the job
and uh Le Le's on The Griddle
over here son he's up hang in
there devils in a second I love it we
cut it short and then we'll do a we'll
do a periscope with the lights off this
Black Sabbath we sold ourselves for rock
and roll and we'll lock the door and
make bets to see how long it take before
Lee comes shooting out the window oh we
locked a thick we locked this uh in our
town we lock this big girl one time we
ate some acid and we locked this big
girl into a room at this party and uh
and we kept going in there with
pots of warm water
pouring it on I feel bad I feel horrible
dude I didn't look we was kids and we're
on acid
dude and then bro you can't tell me this
story when I'm straight you got to tell
me I'm mushrooms you loock the girl I
just remember how old were you I just
remembered it probably 16 that's
terrible I know but here's the thing
let's say I was 14 that way it makes it
sound not as
bad but look she ate ate no she ate acid
with us bro she ate asked it with us
dude and what happened was and we kept
going in the room with like these pots
of warm I don't know why we had the pots
of warm water because I think we just
were up dude and we would like
pour a little on her but not like
torches she wasn't in a cage or nothing
she was just you know free range in this
room right but I think she was scared to
come out and one time we went in bro we
heard this loud sound and we went in and
I wonder why she had ran against one of
the walls so hard bro had moved
the entire wall in this house dude huge
girl about two 240 lbs beautiful girl
too the most beautiful biggest girl that
I've ever known oh my God uh beautiful
girl beautiful hair beautiful face large
just large and beautiful but she
got lifted bro and uh
yeah man I just came down a little
bit off that I just had a little
mushroom high yeah so I get
what you talking about I get this job
boulder oh yeah I'm making dick for
wages and they put me as a shagger it's
a body shop combination detail shot
uhhuh and they made me a shager which
means I clean bathrooms I take garbage
out I pick up customers you know and it
was 175 a week for like 90 hours
like I I was the first one there I had
to be there at 700 the thing opened at
8:30 or 800 and I had to be there at 7
to sweep and 175 a week for 175
a week I clean off all the cars
start them all up warm them in bring
them into the body shop according to
order numbers I did the whole thing man
and I liked it listen I was up
for a long time this was a great little
job for me but you know what man 175 for
all these hours these are
getting fat off me and I'm like it
I want to go in the detail shop so I
started petitioning to go in the detail
shop I was a really good shagger
so they knew my work ethic the guy was
from New York State Steve
something there's so many Steves
in my life that every time I look up his
name and Facebook but he was
good to me Steve in fact Steve was the
dude who introduced me to steveen
Tidwell the dude who I kidnapped Kent
Vel with so like that's how I knew all
these guys so I petition Steve I go
Steve That's it man I'm a great shagger
I want the job in the back you
know I'm sick and tired of making 175
yeah I want to make 200 bucks a
day like these ganoes yeah so
one of the guys heard me and he didn't
like me his name was Dirk something oh
Dirk dirty Dirk wasn't a tough
guy but he was one of these guys that
would fight me to the end but and he had
the body shop guys he had the the the
whatever guys the the the detailers
detailers they were on his side the
detailers were kind of a little
but you know I knew like two of them
that were really cool the other two were
and
then yeah and he was a supervisor
hierarchy so I said how am I going to
get this I see a dead rat
in a corner oh and I took it and I put
in his jacket pocket Dam that's old
school I put it in his jacket pocket the
next morning this guy comes in with a
dent in his car and the jacket holding
on to it he he drove home all night with
the mouse in his
pocket and then the next morning he
started his car reached in for a
pack of cigarettes and there's this
rat this F and he crashed the
car he
got that's what the dent was for oh
yeah he I mean he up the side of
his car into like a tree something like
that him you know me do he loved
this car he was one of those dude love
this car he waxs it out and every day
and I'm like get the out of
here poorly oh looking beautiful man Le
too deep Le do another star to balance
you yeah you got to balance your
pH you need some uh a little bit
ofada bro we need to hit up the
Mexican milk made bro get it a spray in
your mouth a little Lee get your
back you got to baby bird your little
get your back on the branch get your
back on the branch up for you
people are not watching this live dude
uh I remember one time we uh this
uh um you me out to death what you
hum me to
death me to
death anything you say to death is
always
funny yes yes
me joy a million I used to have
a friend that he was describing the girl
I was dating to me it was her father and
he goes thank God you got her off me he
goes when she was a kid I used to call
her dollar to death cuz she dollar the
death dollar debt that's a great
name what does that mean dollar debt
give me a dollar give me a dollar give
me how many dollars yeah how
many dollars do you need to day
it was dollar de
dude I remember
this yeah now I feel bad about we did it
that bigger girl bro you can't you can't
you know but we didn't do it cuz she was
big we just did it she just wanted to
she just got up and she couldn't
get out the room you know like I got
one of my best friends got
up one time and he started talking about
Asian people we never even seen any
Asians in our life and he started in
your life no and I guess maybe like in a
past life he might have known some
Asians you know and so he starts
bringing up their names bro and knowing
them and knowing about him on this
mattress in this house and I'm like
dude you're up bro I'm leaving
right so apparently I'm the kind of
friend that when your friend is at his
worst you leave bro cuz I was he
talking about Chinese people yeah never
met Chinese people we never known any so
what is he saying he's just saying like
hey you remember like s like you
remember Sun lamb BR he was
there for us you know and all this
I'm like sun lamb bro we don't know him
dude you know he was like
talking about Dorothy Dorothy Dorothy
you know we didn't know any Asians bro
and I'm like I got to get away from so
where you came from when you grew up
there was no Asians in that neighborhood
not when you were there now there's
probably four yeah right now there's no
we live in a small town dude I mean I
remember the population oh we probably
had about 2,000 growing up oh this
one dude I remember was trying to be an
Elvis impersonator he said he was an
Elvis impersonator bro but he was just
uh a alcoholic you know what I'm
saying like we don't need any Elvis bro
you know we got 2,000 people we need
gas money and we need yeah we
need ideas bro give us some
ideas those Elvis impersonators
are pay in the
ass they really are get a life I
got to tell you something you know I
told Lee before when I first got into
comedy when I got serious about it in 94
there was a guy in
Denver who used to go to Comedy Works
and I know his haircut look familiar you
like when you look at somebody like the
heck it looks familiar but who am I I'm
on coke pills you know I'm being eating
badass I'm eating bad I got terrible
habits who am I have around with
somebody's haircut I got
terrible habits and all of a sudden I
get a call from the guy and he goes hey
I'm doing a gig uh you know dog in those
days 50 bucks you know I'm like yeah
I'll be there an hour and I show up and
he comes to the door and he's got away
350 and he's got the belt on the whole
Elvis suit and D you know I mean the guy
is did you know that was going to be
like that no yeah I knew the whole time
I was at home preparing for this no
when I walk in the door there he
is all bigger than life I when
they surprise you that and he's like I'm
the Elvis person they just do 10 minutes
in front of
me and you know what I think I was
supposed to get 50 bucks he gave me a
yard stick wow and then he calls me
three months later he goes hey I opened
up a bar hilarious uhhuh so I get to
this bar it's Wednesday nights he's the
main act uhhuh and he brings up three
Comedians and at the end he sings all
those Elvis songs and he's
horrible yeah I mean he's
horrible he's smoking cigarettes his
teeth are green boozing he's fat
he had let himself go but sounds like
Elvis sounds voice but you know what
this guy did he was an Elvis
impersonator and somewhere that was his
claim to fame I mean the whole inside of
the club was Elvis themed right but it
had a wall of writeups about him you
know all the awards he want and he
was a Vegas boy and he was no
good maybe at some point I mean you know
at this point and he
uh he um bought this club they
bought him out in Vegas like they bought
him out because his voice is so bad I
don't know and he went to
Colorado and opened up a little
bar like it wasn't even a bar guy it was
like an old like a an old Boutique that
he turned into a bar during the week and
he's sang Elvis song it was a woman's
closet hysterical hysterical but you
know what man whatever the guy said he
would always pay me he paid me double he
never tried to stick a finger on my ass
he never did drugs or nothing but he
always bought me a drink he go take a
drink you know don't he goes I'm not
going to give you two cuz I'm not going
to be responsible for you driving right
even if you have money I don't want you
drink in here go drink next door yeah
but he was solid like he liked me as a
comic and he always paid me and he
didn't blow smoke up my ass it's not
like he was going to make a video and
take me to Vegas thinking back and I
forgot his name and I'm really sorry
good dude he was just a terrible Elvis
yeah I wonder if Elvis no I
think if Elvis came back to life he'd
shoot half these impers like that's hell
for Elvis like that's his that's a great
movie Elvis comes back and
imperson his dog let's hit all
the bad ones that'll make
it instead of Isis coming in and
shooting everybody it's a fat Elvis with
a missing leg and he's decapitated neck
and he he shoots people he goes to
the kitchen he takes something he and
and the cops don't mess with cuz
it's Elvis they know dude was the worst
bro he was the wor and he wasn't like he
had no work they let him dress up like
they dress him up like Santa around
Christmas let him wave at the trains and
coming into town you know like
seasonal greeter you know and uh and
he'd always like like you'd see him and
he'd be like uhhuh you know it's like
kill the out yeah just it's just us
you're an alcoholic yeah you're a
Elvis in person you're not even
in uniform you're the alley right now
and uh his kids he made them be
Pentecostal he had four kids no Mom he
made them be Pentecostals kept them in
the yard what's Pentecostal mean it just
means they wear like big clothes and
believe in like God like I think a lot
you know but they wear like just huge
clothes like cheap clothes like they
look like like the kids look like rodeo
clowns you know like they just look you
know like and it the girl let me feel a
breast actually one time through the bar
they had a bar wire fener around their
house like girl let me feel some
titty uh what was her name what
was it Barbara Barbara I think or
Barbara B Barbara breast
right let me feel that hard
nipple through some T through some
barar right uh his son used to
eat tuna and ice cream every day
and vomit on the bus dude so people
would beat him
up wait a second would he eat the V
would he eat the tuna first or the ice
cream I don't know he showed up with
them already in him and people would
beat him and he'd already be
sick he'd already be sick dude and the
dad the dad uh made the kid a wooden
shirt one year for Christmas
dude made him a shirt out of
wood I'm coming up from church it's
Wednesday and they're in the garage bro
I swear to God was it like cool or was
it just like a big box it was horrible I
mean at the time it was cool you know at
the time it was was I mean it was kind
of beautiful the kid like cried and
when he when he put him in
it I could have been at home right now
watching Empire jumping up and down with
black
people donuts and and
you're over here telling me this crazy
who else eats a mushroom on a
Wednesday I'm sitting here going dude
what is wrong with me I should know
better but I don't give a anymore
like it's to the point in my life where
you know what I look at my drawer and I
got Quaaludes in there I got
grenades you got baby pacifiers
I'm done I got to do all the that's
in there baby pacifiers but those are
for
you you know you look at all this
mushrooms and you go on the road and
you're like what the people
actually doing this every night and
I'm sitting you know yeah but my friends
today they were excited like you're
going on you're going with mad
flavor dude we're going to tune in you
know I mean so I think that that you
know we're getting to live some of a
dream that other people don't get to
live you know when you're sitting at
home and you know you probably sit next
to your wife or your husband um or you
know somebody you might not even
maybe you do love him still but who
knows you know you need a little
speed bump you know but yeah that dude
made his son a wooden shirt and then
some kids spray pin his schwas stickers
on it man that's how
you can't wash your shirt H yeah they
spray painted swastick is on the wood
but no we we didn't have any Jews either
we didn't have anybody you know people
just seen like the schwas STI on like a
pamphlet or something you know but we
didn't have any Jews it was just you
know just local art and somebody
spray painted the D now what was the
population how many black people out of
2000 you probably had I would guess
about 1100 brothers and they were
gaining ground quick dude you could hear
them at
nighto if you put your ear up to the
woods that's what they would say no no
any Latinos and that no Market at that
time creeping in how long one kid how
long have you been gone for now one kid
I've been gone for from that town I've
been gone for I left there when I was
probably maybe 13 I've been gone yeah
I'm 36 now whatever that is 23 23 years
thanks L that's a real Jew even with
mushroom I even need a
calculator he could be passed out he'll
just pop his head 23 and he'll go right
back to sleep little sleep at me he's
still giving
estimates uh they had one Mexican kid
this kid uh Nicholas man the Raper he
supposed to write rapper on his
shirt I don't if I told you oh yeah tell
about that Raper rap yeah they
wrote Raper and they expelled him that
was the first Mexican we ever had what
is it was your dad Spanish uh well my
dad was Nicaraguan I I'm polish
Nicaraguan I'm one of the few you know
there's probably 11 of us out there
Polish Nicaraguan that is
crazy yeah man so it's getting
when you where did you move then moved
to this neighboring town I went and like
live with a family that had like uh like
I got emancipated and then live with a
different family so and they were cool
they were cool it's more
organized it was more it's crazy cuz I
always think of when my mom died we
didn't do no paperwork yeah like I just
moved into people's houses I just
changed my address at school that's it
there was no paperwork I didn't
I didn't do nothing that was it
crazy yeah what's weird about when
something like that happens when you're
young is that there's no there's no real
stop like life just goes on that's when
you realize that life just goes
on when something heavy like that
happens you lose a parent and the next
day is just there it's like and then the
next day is there I spoke to a teacher
of mine that just lost his mom this
guy's
64 6 4 and he's like I think a
year every day since my mom died because
I can't imagine how you did it it's
being like bulletproof you're like
bulletproof at that age you don't even
know what's going on but it catches up
with with you all that catches up
with you it caught up with me 5 years
later really yeah yeah it hit home cuz
you're young you're involved in
activities you have so much going on
yeah that it never really sets in it
sets in like level
four and then Through The Years you
still have to pay for that yeah you
still going to have to do that work
you're going to talk to somebody for me
it was just going in a closet by
myself at night and getting high for 12
hours damn 11
that's how that's that's when you know
like I got to high like anybody else you
do a couple lines you giggle yeah but
then the grams chopped up
between four people become grams divided
by two people oh yeah and then all a
sudden one night you find yourself with
a package at home like you you actually
like you split the gram and you have two
bumps at home you oh yeah I should have
brought more and that's the beginning of
the end that's yeah I've been at the end
before people don't know the beginning
of the end the end it's when you start
going home the end is by yourself
knowing you're like I'm locking the door
yeah I got booze I got ice cubes I got
pornography I got pornography I got
straws I got everything I don't need
nobody that's worst up that's
when your mind is somewhere else oh when
it's 7:00 a.m. you're tugging on a
hot dick that's limp oh you're
in the shower now trying to fantasize a
fourth grade banging some it's horrible
it's a horrible existence but that it's
cool when you're out with people and
talking you know you get in your car and
there's no more blow and nobody has to
go get another package that's when it's
fun those days it's gone okay what do we
do now I don't know we smoke pot till
everybody passes out that's it but then
one day that's how it starts you're by
yourself and then you start calling
people when you're by yourself to get
more yeah I I used to go to El
Padre done that recently I used to go to
El Padre by a gram at at 9:00 damn over
there on Sunset yeah and then run home
do the whole gram in two
lines and by 1:00 start coming down and
I call another guy that was a DJ and he
would come over at 1:15 1:30 when he got
off work at somewhere in Hollywood there
what the did I call them I called
them something I don't know my brain is
traveling right now bro I feel
like a spaceship just took off
out of my head a little how about you
Lee how you feeling a good explanation
of what's going on was it go with that
dude we are we got hit hard I'm more
tired than anything I didn't sleep last
night you didn't no I got home from we
got home at 12:30 last night yeah when I
went in the house drank some water took
my shoes off put the TV on I thought it
was 11:15 yeah next thing you know it's
2 and it was 12 30
12:25 Le called me like at
12:35 to say I'm walking in my door or
something he said yeah I think I stayed
up till 1 then I went to bed but I
didn't fall asleep it didn't hit home I
started tossing and turning tossing and
turning thinking about your set thinking
about who is there you know it's too
real when you're there sometimes right
sometimes you go to those parties or
functions and you see somebody like Theo
V but he's
talking and I'm talking and Theo's cool
Theo no dog we're talking business or
this chick's a a pigeon I'm taking this
victim home with me there's always
something and you go home and that hits
you that night you didn't say hello to
Theo right I feel bad I didn't see Theo
that's the that I go through before
you go to sleep that's nice cuz you're a
friendly dude that that a lot of people
bro when that doesn't go through
your head I think that's when you're you
know that's when something's wrong well
you're getting high listen you're
getting high you're having a
cocktail so sometimes the uh
camera moves really fast yeah it's not
till you go home and look at the
paperwork look at the film yeah you're
editing the film you're seeing what's
going on and now is when you see oh
I saw Theo there yeah Lee did
you see Theo there yet what happened to
him I don't know he was talking to some
he didn't say hello to you NE no was he
mad n he smiled but he was talking to
some broad and some guy and they were
talking about videos and next thing you
know you're off and then next morning
you'll say the same thing yeah I seen
Joey there last night the happened
how the didn't I talk to him I
didn't talk to him that's what happen
you know you go home and you play that
channel out and I wasn't
drinking I don't drink yeah I just smoke
dope I can't imagine if I I remember
when I used to drink and have to
decipher the night the next morning you
just wake up and just lay in bed for 10
minutes yeah you pee you grab something
to drink you sit back down and you're
like what the happened last night
and you see little flashes and then you
know you put together and then the
next thing you know your buddy calls you
did you hook up with that girl what
happened to you that monster
yeah it's always some monster
dude bro I remember this one girl I
brought uh we had this thing for a while
if you would Vis Queen a chick right and
that's if you would bring a chick home
and she would fall as sleep or at her
place or your place and you'd put like a
piece of visqueen over her body right
what the hell is she was asleep it's
like uh you know what it is it's like
that that that material they rain and
like for rainers keep rain on stuff
what the people you hang out with
because I hear like if you really want
to kind of spook a girl then uh that's
like if I hear from a woman I heard who
woke up under some V Queen once she said
it was the scariest experience of her
life bro so then we were like oh we got
to do this to some chicks right so we
had this thing we would put this
queen
over
is it like the blue thing that they put
down it always has holes at the end
because they always need to rope it
together it's clear no it's clear it's
the clear stuff oh the clear stuff okay
okay okay I'm getting all conf it's a
little thicker yeah it's a little
thicker oh yeah miss queen okay you wake
up that you know what I used to use that
for roofing yeah yeah it's for that it's
for painting for the first layer of
roofing in Colorado you got to use
visqueen because it's cold it was cold
at the time the first 18 in or something
like that if it's the same yeah yeah
yeah it's a little thicker but this
comes with glue on it or it doesn't who
the know what the do I know I
don't remember there about 30
chicks out there that have woke up under
some Vis Queen you know who you
are you know what I'm saying is it just
a board of visqueen on them no boards no
boards that's Gangsta talkg just
a visqueen just a visqueen and they I'm
sure they wake up and they think theyve
been murdered you know they probably
think they're going to see a detective
when they pull that off bro oh my
God that's ganga son if you could do
that that's ganga uh we did that dude
would you watch them wake up or would
you just no we wouldn't watch them
wake up Dexter damn dog we left
dude we had to go no we had to go to the
airport I'm sorry Leon I'm not trying to
be rude uh just F I'm just
up now listen I know Leo long time Lee
always ask you the million dollar
question oh yeah Lee's known for the
million dollar question typical Hebrew
right hit you with that
typical Hebrew I love
it damn this is a podcast ladies
gentl talking laughing
giggling for real don't get me
wrong some of this mushroom p is helping
this laughter we'll listen to
this tomorrow and go what the we
talking about what the is wrong
with us you H to kill us but you
got to loosen up from time to time
people every once while you got to take
the stick out of your ass and giggle and
wake up the next morning and go wow take
out a Mexican girl a girl you don't
even know what she's saying bro you know
I mean but make sure the expression on
her face is positive you know what I'm
saying cuz otherwise that might be
illegal but that used to be something I
would do when I got into town man I
would have somebody set me up with a
girl who I didn't know what she was
saying at all and I would go out and I
would just try to use like my you know
just like uh regular you know like just
it's almost like playing clue it's like
playing it's like playing charades but
you at the end you know that's what
it's like dude take somebody out you
don't know learn something he looking
like what meet a girl take a girl out
from nairoby or from uh China
you know somewhere what do you want no
it's just interesting because I was
telling Steve Simone like you you were
talking to like a group of five or six
guys last night and you like could talk
to every all of them at once like
command it like the circle and it's just
I can't do that and something like it's
it's like a something i' always want to
do I don't know it's just cool like like
I'm always a more oneon-one kind of
person yeah but to be able to talk to to
command the attention of like six people
it was it was just cool to watch I wish
I could be more one-on-one people tell
me I can't I'm not good one-on-one so I
I'd trade with you no you know I'm good
one on one when it's people like that
you're just telling the story you know
that's the I used to do growing up
at hash WS where there's eight
hanging on the corner if
you got to where to I grew up if you
want to say a word and people pay
attention you better be funny you got
one shot at this right cuz there eight
that can run with M
especially in your area I'm sure follow
me so yeah in the Southeast had to be
able to speak and people when you bang
you better bang so they listen to you
cuz you only got like four bangs left
right then people won't pay attention to
you that's yeah all right keep it up get
a notebook quit your day job whatever
the
yeah dude that used to be the
funnest man was making people laugh at
the lunch table man that was the funnest
thing until they had milk spray out of
their nose that's when I would leave and
it always be the Bell would ring
everybody be back in class and me one
would just keep listening
for some reason I would just hold him by
his arms across the table and
keep telling him until it
sprayed out of his nose and then I would
leave dude you know they had a the first
wiger I ever met was from our town bro I
think the first wig I ever man this kid
named Brian St Pierre bro and they put
him in class he was a white dude that
was trying to be black yeah he was a
white dude they he move from I don't
nowhere bro he just you
know he was raised like kind of like you
know he was like mowle you know like he
was just spent a little bit of
time on the other side of town you know
and the brothers really got a hold of
him and uh and he was cool though he was
a cool dude man mly he was bro he was
like a mly you know my whole body just
shook I thought it was an earthquake for
a
minute I said in yoga bro I said in y
but look man they put him in the
mentally handicapped class bro cuz they'
never seen it before they'd never seen
it before they put him in class with
kids with Down Syndrome with kids with
in wheelchairs they put him what just a
dude who had like couldn't he just be
like hey guys I'm this just the way I
want to talk I don't even know what the
you saying Le right now you sound
like I'm right now they probably put you
in that class right now with me dude I
don't even know what you're
saying you like that
they put the wigger in in the
rard in the special class that's what
you sounded that's what that dude
sounded like I want a dollar
today like cousin it what the
he say I'm over here
y before we started Lee kept thinking he
was here to buzz it in oh my God people
we started late wee was looking around
the room like and now he's making a
buzzing in the mic listen to him he's
the walking Buzz over here
oh when I was when I was when I was 19 I
went to the movies with Louis
Casto and this dude Kurt D Lorenzo it
was the night after ACDC at the
Palladium it was it was like summer of
19 80 yeah it was right after
ACDC came back mhm so it was a Saturday
night we going to the movies to watch I
have no idea and on the way back me and
Casto gave each other a look uhhuh and
KK kept saying I hear something cuz the
night before we did acid and blow and
throughout the whole night he kept
saying he kept saying I keep hearing my
ears right you know when you're
16 and you do a gram of blow a
ass your fure listen him and I did we
stopped one of the most awkward people I
grew up in a cocaine culture so I knew
when people were doing it my mom's hand
would stick close to a tit yeah a little
little T-Rex what's a little
T-Rex and my mom was one of those but I
hand like you thought it belonged to
somebody else and right so I knew
the hand
movement uh when I was 16 I got a job at
renle Lumber and there was a guy there
who blew my
mind it was on the tip of my tongue now
I forgot the guy's name oh dude
I forgot what I was talking about it
really don't matter the guy was an Irish
dude really nice guy but once he did one
line of coke mhm every inhibition every
physical strength he had would dissolve
and he would do like Duck faces in his
hand his name is Jack F fin Jack Finn
I'll never forget the one day Jack fined
he started swimming gu he was
up on a Saturday and he walks
into work I'm 16 he walks into work all
up that's the first time I heard
that expression he goes boss let me get
a 100 on the arm till Monday and the
boss looks at me goes my arms are heavy
and walked away I'll never forget that
expression but jackf was a fiend for
yeah for once he started once he
if he the word on the street was Jack
fin is tremendous until alcohol hits his
tongue right then it's a different you
should have seen it and he was
tremendous he'd give you money when he
was drunk he was a great guy but just to
see the transformation but Jack Finn had
something else Jack Finn hung out a
dirty Barn we Hawking which is we
Hawking sounds but they got some
gutter this is this is 1980 before
they started breaking those
stones wow the people that hung in we
honking were Savages damn and
they sold this cocaine that just looking
at it with your eyes and I had
done tceo and the night ACDC came back
to the Palladium oh we used to sell
hamsters after the ACDC shows full
circle would you stop at the
at the AC this is when Bon Scott
died and the Brian Johnson joined the
band this how old I am this was
huge him and me and Kurt were walking
into the City and we go where are we
going to get Coke we were going to take
a bus from un City New Jersey we go
let's take a cab down a we hawk and we
saw Jack Finn and for 50 bucks he gave
us a bottle and we got out of there we
got back in the cab we made the cab wait
for us and in the cab we did little
bumps of coke this is when it came in a
bottle with a spoon yeah
woo there was not a gram in there they
had to be like 910 of a grand right me
and Kurt kept doing it and it was August
2nd 19 1980 and it had to be
95 uh what's the temperature 95° but
100% humidity in New York City right and
I'll never forget I had Le jeans on with
a white T-shirt and sneakers
mhm and that's the first time ever that
even after the fact that I got home you
thought you might be no my pants were
drenched and my socks were drenched from
my sweat wow like I had sweat so much at
this concert I jumped up and down so
much me and Good Feeling then in the
concert me and Kurt popped the acid and
we had like vodka and Gatorade we're
drinking it how old were you guys 16 oh
good 16 17 tops we're lit yeah
we get out of the concert we still got
to half that VI blow yeah we're on the
train we're on the whatever the the
train back to New York we're doing
bumps you guys are a couple of so we
didn't finish the Kurt went home I went
to wherever I was living next morning I
wake up there's Coke I'm
up so the next day it's a light night
right in those days that was called a
light night that was a Friday night or
whatever yeah it was a Friday night so
Saturday Saturday go mov so let's go to
the movies yeah so we went to the movies
but that whole day Kirk kept
saying look my ears are still ringing
from the blow last night that's how good
that coke was so we went to here's the
whole day passes that morning he said it
but the whole day passes we're at a
movie now we walk out of at 11:00 at
night never forget it was raining and
we're walking back down from fairw New
Jersey into North Bergen it's
raining and KK kept
saying guys my ears are still ringing
and all of a sudden I I look at Digger
and Digger looks at me and we play it
and we're like I hear some ringing too
Kur looks at me and I'm like yeah I hear
some ringing I hear some ringing I
sold it you know me dog yeah I
hear it I can't believe it CT's
like you guys hear it this ain't me what
the and there was a pothole there
was a pothole like 8 ft away it just
rained there was gut of water in there
Kur ran over took that pothole water and
started splashing in his face way and
he's like okay I'm good now you guys
still hear the ringing and we're like we
hear it he just took off with
that puddle water on his face way dude
oh my God ever see him again yeah the
next day was a good he just died 6
months ago poor he bought a Subway
sandwich went outside open didn't killed
the whole F he didn't even eat the
sandwich he just looked at it and killed
them that's how he died that's a he just
bought a Subway sandwich and he
had he walked outside he got to switch
to quiz no I'm telling you that Subway I
should kill a I've been
telling Le for years one day he's like
you know man I
like I thought about what you said man
and I think you're right those people
have no respect the
bread I had I had a guy who worked at
Subway told me Lee was in there twice a
day every day at attention dog
damn that's how loyal this
had a loyalty
card he knew the Mexicans in handicap
fck that chick that don't lift the right
hand cuz he got hit by a car he won't
he knew her name he
knew I knew the shifts they got a one
you knew their shifts oh he knew shifts
he knew who gave you more lettuce Jesus
Christ they knew him I'm telling
you he was like the co-assistant
manager wow bro that's crazy Lorenzo in
real life died six months ago
rest in peace like everybody it was
shocking yeah he bought a Subway sand
how they knew was they had to get the
cameras from the Subway sandwich
and they sit down open it up he smell
that
I didn't kick the
buck your dear friend what what he he's
your dear friend and he kicked the bu
yeah that's sad man dude rest in peace
yeah rest in peace for sure man
uh
first concert dude first concert I ever
went
to uh this pedophile took us right I'm
not even joking dude rest in peace he's
dead this D Richard langest time bro his
family owned a Deli dude over
new one's famous how did he bring you to
a country yeah tell you me and my little
girlfriend at the time Jessica we met
him at church right cuz he was uh I
guess he was uh daylighting as a decent
person
right so we met him at church okay so I
was like hey you know that's uh and they
called him big Richard bro cuz he was
big and he had all the you know
his skin was scab and up he had
different colors on his arms and we're
like you know the Lord's leopard
print was coming out of him
right oh my God so we went over to his
house we like let's go to his house and
uh take him some cookies on Sunday and
watch the Saints game with him right not
for nothing we shouldn't ate that second
step we shouldn't no I'm up to the
I'm crying oh my God I'm crying and I
have no worries I'm sorry keep going
okay I'm sorry no look I want I'm I just
want to let you know I'm up to
the gills there's a lot of nights
there's a lot of nights I can't even
I walk out of here he's all
up and I don't get it tonight is my
God's punishment I'm up I should
have not ate that second step that
was grown in cow
I can still taste it in my mouth I
need to go home and line two
times
so we went over to the dude's house
right we took some cookies over there
watch a Saints game then he started
substitute teaching at the school I was
going to you know big Richard big
Richard and the kids listen parents I'm
going over my buddy what to C with this
old man and want well I told the guy
like my parents was out of the picture I
told the girl parents like oh do we she
was there the mother was there we met
him at church like yeah that's sweetie y
go over there not a substitute to school
yes he started
sub I didn't realize at the time like
now I realize it's ironic the dude
starts subbing cuz I'll be
honest I was a handsome kid you know the
dude starts uping I have long
hair beautiful hair strong in a
you know chest and
shoulders like a like the
strongest French Bulldog you ever seen
right so uh we go over to his house then
the next time I see him at substitute at
the school then he's like yeah come back
over I'm like my girl can't come he's
like oh just come over watch a Saints
game right I come over he breaks out a
little bit of herb right gets me high
right so then the next couple of times I
start bringing my friends over there
dude then he starts like getting
us all stoned and everybody we're
smoking out of apples and we're doing
all kinds of fancy stunts you know just
herb stunts you know my buddy
Scott my buddy Glenn we're over there
herbing up with uh big Richard you know
and we kind of you smoke a little extra
with him because you think he might die
you know he's older he's in his 80s you
know he's in his 80s what he still
perver
yeah bro look you how can you be A8 and
still be perverting you got to respect
the game this is way before viag this
guy got dick he he just saw an ice cream
truck he got hard you know what I'm
saying I think he just yeah he just
wanted a kid to look at it the are
you 80 and still perverting so he was
out there PV bro you know what I'm
saying so one time dude uh and I'll tell
you how we found out that he was a
pervert right we didn't tell me
it didn't catch on with us right so we
dumb dude I'm so gullible bro I
could have been molested a million times
like I'm going tell this molesters if
you're out there bro do you have so many
fans I'm sure you got about 30
child molester fans statistically
bro statistically statistically dude me
in here statistically bro you probably
got 30 fans of the ches you missed your
chance I'm going say that you missed
your chance with this kid
Dynamite dude cuz I was gullible bro and
I was a good kid and I was strong bro
handsome long hair but uh anyway uh well
Joy's
gone Joey left bro you would to
finish telling you what what's up you
don't even know you if finish telling
you the story or not go for
give me a update me so you even know
what the story was about do you
know I knew a second ago but
now keep just keep going from where you
told it cuz then people all right so the
child molested bro we didn't know we
didn't know we just thought he was a 80y
old man so he had like a full career yes
dude like in our town you could be 80
and still substitute teach I guess right
so that's
like
sorry thought you just left mushroom my
pe's coming out green oh my
dick feels all lit up oh how's
your dick got to do
it you know Le we're going to have to do
heroin on this show No not tonight
though man not okay good get
a we have to get a guest that's down
okay that'll be the end like that
that'll be the end like unless y'all
have never done it I might do it with
y'all first time or did it when I was
locked up oh you've done it oh my God
yeah but never with a needle like I'm a
I would never do it with a needle
but now I can handle it with a needle
I'll put Santana on on the iTunes and
look the other way on the iPod and look
the other
way there's a little black chick down at
Bob Hope that chick you don't even feel
it taking the blood out of your arms
damn oh she's Hope Airport or
hospital I'm serious the
hospital
okay oh my god dude can I when I walk
when I walk in there in the Bob ho when
I got to give a physical or whatever I
always see her and I get happy because
I'm dead serious yeah she's been the
she's a champ huh there's a little
Filipino chk up here up at this one up
here in the valley Martin St
Lauren whatever that hospital is over
here right there by the Boston by the
Boston Market I don't know the
name they always I'm just saying they
always give names to all the hospitals
out here yeah like who gives a just
right Hospital on the hospit I just want
to know where where I go I to death you
think I'm going to go drive name I don't
think that's a hospital name Martin St
Len is a perfume I don't
know I don't know what I look
like I'm sophisticated I'm not
sophisticated dude I'm not
um but here I just want to at least let
everybody know that the pedophile died I
don't some what people thinking that he
was 80 I couldn't even see him be 90 and
still
Jesus Christ a 90y old pedophile
somebody has not been doing their
job he took us to a Maryland
Manson concert my first concert ever
been to the time he was probably about
82 right we were 14 bro he takes us to
Manon or 15 but we I remember being in
the bathroom me and my buddy Scott and
uh somebody's like how old is those kids
and somebody else is like oh they're
like 13 and I remember some the
guy going oh somebody's going to
them that's what the dude said
bro in the bathroom an adult we just
like what dude and then we were back in
the in an audience just to say that not
even go home and go what happened to
those two kids get you is
laying there in bed that night you going
I'm going to say my prayers how can you
say your prayers don't you say what
happened to those two kids they might be
getting right now nobody
intervene I
know what Savage would say that
to some kids
what a heartless Muppet Monsters
what about their parents like was it
just like free like a
babyit oh I don't know are you
crazy like how where were the parents
the his parents went home watching
daytime television he's 14 he told him
he was going to the library to do a
book report and the girl told
her parents the same thing but they
already had it worked out with this
82-year-old pedophile that we'll go to
the Madison Maryland Madison concert and
after the concert we'll see what happens
what did he dress like did he dress like
an old man or did he dress like a no he
dressed like Tom
Jones he's dressed what does he look
like he's dressed like in your vision of
him it was either like a old man with
like khakis and a brown belt what
difference would it make what difference
would it make he said he do he
can't disguise who you you the
Tom Ford of pedophile
you give a he's a profiler of
pedophiles you can't what pedophiles
wear who the they're 82 yeah 82 and
they're going to Maryland Manson
concerts like I didn't know he were like
the jeans in the shirt like the maryn
Manson shirt like tried to rock out in
82 what
dude what are you saying I'm not
blaming it on you bro I am lit
bro Asian amans right there
Coco oh my God what's the matter Le it's
a beautiful night to be alive
people this is
it do you could sit there and go ah I
owe this guy 800 I owe this guy oh you
can giggle your way to who a
you many a night I sat
there for years wasting my time laying
there wasting your time what and at the
end they ain't going to do dick changed
it for you man cuz I did I literally
feel like I spent the last sit there at
night like a Momo you know listen man
it's a it's a it's a DNA thing with me
you know I'm the type of guy if I go out
before I come home I drive by
Le you know or I drive by felicies
anybody in my B chers just to make sure
the house is not on fire yeah it's not
like I knock on the door and go hey
Joey's out here patrolling the area no I
just drive Joy's out here using
facial moisturizer
no I'll be honest bro I use
facial moisturizer bro I'll admit some
dude I'll get some off my
chest I use facial moisturizer bro uh
what else dude uh I wet the bed
till I was 28 I still wet the bed yeah
you never mind not not every week yeah
not every week like a
week I like a be once a year you
to peanut bed you go let it go
let the go yeah once a year I said this
ain't for you toilet now keep it
from myself
son I did like into like Middle School
you did yeah it was
tough it was talk cuz like you can't
control it that is true you can't
control it and other kids like you can't
go sleep at other kids houses uh I'm
going to sit there like a
Mo come to summer camp I can't yeah you
can't you got to bring special cheats
yeah you yeah you show up I used have to
bring special sheets when I went to
Sacred Heart damn I used to have those
special the one that they put under the
sheets like Rubble like a baby
and it sounded when you got on the bed
it sounded like yeah like yeah
Grandma's friend this sounds like
like break dude they used to have a
buzzer did they ever give you that the
buzzer if it got wet it would go off and
wake you up no they had these buzzer
underwear in in an early 9s or late 80s
and I remember they gave them to me if
it buzz if it buzzed and it went off it
would wake you up and uh you execution
yeah oh it's a bad idea for sure I'm
sure some I'm sure some
was that second stem we ate that was a
bad yeah I got to be on stage in
a little while yeah you might as well
call up now yeah you ain't driving you
don't oh I can I but I didn't smoke any
weed though doesn't matter that
tell that lies to you mushrooms lie
to you all those SI cyber mushrooms assd
they lie to you like I just got a good
laugh you get in the car you start that
a and you get that second
Rush yeah this is deadly just comes
at you like away
[Music]
yeah you might as well we got some weed
we got some record players you
know that's it listen to music
get stoned I didn't bring enough weeds
Le never wants to get high so I
just brought a little canister full you
know what I'm saying dude I'll tell you
oh the child molested let me just at
least yeah he died he died in prison
everybody so I don't want people he did
get AR rest at the end well yeah here's
how we knew finally one time we went and
got Stakes with us and my buddy was in
the
kitchen I was in the kitchen I know the
good one's coming I was in the kitchen
and my buddy was sitting in the in the
living room with him and I said I yelled
back into the living room I said hey uh
big
Richard that's what his name was I said
do you have any sour
cream and uh my buddy Scott who's
sitting with him yells back no but you
can have some of this sweet
cream right and then I hear big Richard
who in there sitting next to my
buddy say to him can I have some that's
what he said and that's when it all
changed in our heads like he's not as a
friendly older dude buying us steak and
smoking ass out alive yeah Predator he's
a mad man that's got that
whose goose is loose and he's
looking to touch some young junk
he wants to feel that young
pump in his hands is
loose
so
anyway you know I sit here in front of
you like a man I tell you that I was in
front I grew up around some up
people yeah like I didn't know till
years later you know like now how they
died they died in
prison but I grew up around some
up people like my mom took chances of me
being in that bar yeah she took a big
chance to me when I was a kid she'd tell
me I don't like in that ball cuz
any night shit's going to happen in that
ball when I was young young young I saw
the gay guy Martin pull a gun on are not
doing his brother in that like in the
afternoon like at 2 in the afternoon
over the word mikong over the word
in Spanish that was the first gay
fell pulled a gun oh tremendous gay
fella tremendous
tremendous and then that was that and
then another night there was an incident
where two guys pulled a gun and I was in
there I must have been about 11 and
after that my mom's like you know what
man that's it no more of the bar
but it was my world it was my little
world that little stock office
in the back was me the area was me yeah
is that you Le wasn't snoring
over there just feel like somebody's
howling I'm thinking like it's my my
empyema and it's the
window I'm like my empis is acting
up it's Lee over there passed
out snoring up a storm lifted
like I'm dude I'm and you know
what man I sit here
sometimes that's what I think about at
night like these guys that was
around and not once was I asked to touch
somebody's dick like I read some of this
testimony yeah my heart stops oh yeah
because I didn't come from this world
not at all like not at all one time in
the eth grade I gotten some
guy's car and his hand slipped and he
touched my dick and now I think about
you know now is there an accident no was
purposely he touched my dick on the way
up just to see my
retion and uh if I was Meek he would
have attacked wow at the light the door
opened and I just ran out of there with
the basketball and it's so weird I've
been thinking about this topic cuz now I
have a child and you have to watch him
you know and I was talking to my
sister-in-law and my sister-in-law is
the sweetest person in the world and she
got molested no and she told me one day
we were talking and she was listen do me
a favor no you have a child that just
want you to know something trust nobody
wow like doesn't don't you know watch
those people do surprise attacks don't
trust nobody with your kid yeah yeah you
and you have to and she's a Christian
chick don't curse Don't drink don't
smoke dope you know this isn't like a
paranoid individual she raised a
daughter and I know there was issues one
time and there was issues with a guy at
the church that was a pastor you know it
was why do you think they go to the
church
man it's just a safe place
huh they probably go to the church cuz
honestly they probably feel like they
really need God they just don't want I
mean why did people keep bringing their
children to Michael
Jackson even after it's like the people
who got up I was those people hey Cokes
not for nothing you can't snore Coke
you're going to die and we kept smoking
Coke hey bro you can't keep smoking
cigarettes we keep smoking cigarettes
dog you can't keep going to McDonald's
and eating
cheeseburgers but we love it that's one
thing but for you to bring a child a c l
d to somebody that you know is a
pervert to give you 2 million crazy
that's crazy for years I those
people should be burned man I say burn
them bro dog for years I lived with a
woman that grew up in a
cult and the stories were beyond
belief I mean I got some stories that
are beyond belief if you want to get
down and really get down but why go
there right right there's no reason to
go there yeah that's why I keep I mean
what this girl told me made me hate her
parents because again I don't give a
what you
do I don't give a about what you do
but for you to drag your kids down the
dark cave what's up that's up
what's going on buddy you all right over
there you all right over there you want
to go outside and get some
man oh
okay tell me that you want to go outside
and get some man dude let me do some
let me do some call a
shout out here and we'll wrap this
there we go I think that's
the idea he's feeling up now
don't start let them get electrocuted
it's all right we need somebody to get
electrocuted on the show I got
electrocuted when I was younger man
actually you know who saved me bro I a
brother saved me man and I don't know if
you're out there would you stop already
you got electric yeah it's a fair it's a
fair they used to let us they they used
to let us come in a day early to the
fair and test the rides we didn't
know we didn't know we didn't know we
were getting ped 30 cents get on the
rides look Le on the ones and twos
now like a you look like a
Eminem I'm Not
Afraid
D machine
gun you want some ass dog is it is it
time for you to get it's
a Lee we don't give a
the Cannon hit get up so
yeah you get up you need help to get up
and go get some M you're not going to
vomit on the table like no I'm
okay the cannon hit Lee
man he finally said it we went out
three nights in a row he had me do a
mushrooms on a Monday night my main man
the Australian Warrior a warrior my man
con
Lair burning sage Parish Mickey pearly
sweet cake Bobby and Crystal my main
people in Austin representing amen
Freddy karea over there comic of
the year in Vegas Lance Armen trout my
dog and my band hero Jr making
it happen rest in peace man
they're bad oh they die I
thought it was people who died no no a
call out these people didn't die they're
still alive and kick calling them out if
they were dead I wouldn't give two
Frenchman Lee how you feeling you
need some air you need some water huh
talk to me I'm fine I'm fine I'm just
really I'm I'm good don't keep telling
me you're fine
dog what else throw my dates can I throw
my dates in you can do whatever you want
hold on we ain't even close it out give
me minutes Clos my bad man I'm up
dude no no don't ever say my B
you you're a great guest you made me
dial after here to see you and
Le is a the way to end the month
this is this is a true Labor Day
whatever the it is what is it
Memorial Day Memorial Day it's a week of
soldiers yes you got to pull out the
Flag if you're a Soldier
and and represent these
who get on a plane to go
stab people who are creepy
they're Warriors dude I can never do
that they really do you think about it
the time you have to take a minute I
could stab a you know listen dog
that's the problem that everybody to
wear a suit or a flag on their
lapel that's all amen it's 10
minutes of your time when you're on the
balcony smoking The Joint go Jesus
Christ look at the freedoms that
I have yeah look at the freedoms that I
have right now I'm not doing dick yeah
there's a dude right now who's smoking a
joint over there in war zone but it's
because for the last 16 hours he's been
getting hit with shrapnel and
body parts and smelling people
getting lit on fire yeah and here I am
complaining cuz I got to get up in 4
hours
ain't that a you know what
I'm saying amen so you always got to
think uh that's the real Memorial Day
it's not about a barbecue and
you don't got to look go look at a wall
make believe you give a yeah it's
about just realizing what happened and
going Jesus Christ that's the biggest
thing is realization yes getting on a
plane and going over there to a
foreign place and people talking to you
in a up language and then they're
trying to attack you you don't know
who's who they all look like Le say at
you're like what the is going on in
my world you they don't know you want to
them yeah so this Netflix special
you're doing well with it it's got great
numbers people really like it I talk to
different people godess people like it
uh but you just don't know it just it
just inspired me it it gives you a
chance I know you you know putting out a
special an album you get to see yourself
a little bit it gives you a chance to
step away from that and now for the
first time I feel like you know people
recognize me as a comedian I have fans
for the first time you know and so I
feel like that's like a blessing I
didn't really realize it before I
thought I had a million fans that's a
lot of that's in your head but now I
feel like I have real fans who like want
to know what's going on like I had
people that were excited I was coming
here today you know and so that's good
man that sh that made me feel
sh man we feel human
dude you
know poorly he's having a hard
time he's beautiful though he's a
beautiful he's just got the Lord
running through his face
I love that bro that's Christ that's
Christ reaching for me see that if
you've been with the podcast since day
one he can see that man lee is the
man and tonight we finally
Lee I could see it I could see
it after this podcast goes you have no
idea people see I'm the who
sees him an hour after this and sees how
funny Lee is and he'll pass out right in
front of you yeah oh yeah he's turn the
lights off you put Black Sabbath on
he'll come to life every like eight
minutes and Shane said I'm getting
good and that's the crazy part some
people would be like Ah that's up
but to be brave enough to just let
yourself go like that and relax like
that that's a beauty that I
don't have that I wish I had man you
know he's looking for Easter
baskets bro you know that's beautiful
dude when you just lift out and
start looking for Easter baskets bro you
know when you feel like the
Brothers ain't chasing you anymore oh my
like I I'll be honest with you
dude 90% of my day he's thinking about
brothers chasing I feel like they got
Brothers only two blocks over
leave the brothers alone where you what
saying honestly leave the brothers they
ain't bothering nobody they ain't
chasing nobody I know I know they're not
I'm just saying that's what I just think
in my head want me to share no no I have
the same problem for years okay well and
it just wasn't Brothers I had 15
different from people chasing me I'm the
real deal I had
czechoslovakians I had countries you
never even heard of and people
chasing me Lee wake up you you need some
air you want another star to
balance you out what do we need here no
I don't need another star to balance me
out that's what you need you need some
pH the star I got to he gives me I don't
think you know what PH is cuz listen ph1
is a beautiful thing what we do is he's
got special stars to have a special pH
to bring you back to life a little I
feel like a Christmas traveler
right now I'm telling you dog this is
the way to do it on a Thursday
night sitting around with your little
buddies all right Coco
Diaz we did it I'll be in Cleveland next
weekend at hilarities nope I'm actually
at the uh Hard Rock Casino look at you
right downtown in the middle of
everything Hard Rock rocking
uh so I'm looking forward
to that that's uh Friday through Sunday
in Cleveland the week after that um give
me the paperwork and then where you yet
the week after that cuz it's already the
end of May you know that Joey no
I've been thinking about the same
thing I'm already thinking about
June 1st damn right cuz I got no
business till June 8th yeah I'm at the
Hard Rock roxo in
Cleveland uh it's actually in the BBS
man Hard Rock Ro Casino in Cleveland
Northfield it's called um June 3rd
through the 5th and then I'm at
punchline in Atlanta June 9th through
the 12th you catch me on Doug Benson's
podcast I'll be on his podcast there too
I think they're Taping that there then
I'm going to the beach with my family
we'll be down there in St Joe's
uh I don't know if it's Alabama
or Florida dude it's going to be
up I'll be vlogging a little bit of that
I dropped a vlog on YouTube you can
check it out it's called this past
weekend and that'll be with my family
and then uh that's it man am I
just saying crazy now I'm so
up in July I'll be in uh you're like man
next May I'm
barbec
piz at least I I'm just going through my
calendar dog Jesus Christ give me two
dates he whips out the
he whips out the web page he starts
dropping dates in in
2018 look at the producer dude he's
doing a tour with Mar in
2018 I'll be giving
blood and this other poor zombo
go get some air ready you you going
to sit there m like a Buddhist who's
been
shot hey but look in typical Memorial
Day fashion we ain't leaving this
Soldier we ain't leaving we
ain't leaving this Wounded
Warrior Man and just thank you guys so
much for having me Wounded Warriors you
see those people rip themselves off I
love it dog I hate those people
I hate all those fake
foundations oh all those fake
foundations man yeah it is sad when
people do that kind of anyway why
put why drag a dog in here you want to
give you money bro give your money to
your neighbor find somebody who
you know in person that need a
black dude is 7-Eleven who ain't
bothering nobody the first one at the
door who's polite all right there you go
first one at the door is polite and I
will be at that barbecue I ain't mad at
you know I know you're not let's do this
all right hold on one second in the
Church of What's Happening Now listen
you're unique you don't walk like
anybody you don't talk like anybody you
don't sleep like anybody so why is your
mattress one size fits all because a
customer mattress will cost you $5 to
$10,000 wow until now introducing Helix
sleep where you can buy mattresses
online customized for you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands you
follow me you go to helix.com right now
you answer a few simple questions based
on four key preferences and the result
will be a custom sleep profile used to
build you the most comfortable mattress
listen You'll Ever sleep on your life
everybody has a bum mattress oh
my mattress is horrible dude it's
bum mattress and sometimes they
say well you spend the extra dough this
is the real de holy field and
for couples you customize each side of
the mattress that's your mattress will
arrive in at your door in about a week
and shipping you ready for this is 100%
free healers customers report
30% Improvement in overall sweep Sleep
Quality oh that's you got 100 nights to
try it out and if you don't love it if
you're not in love with it they'll pick
it up for free and give you 100% refund
no questions asked who else does that
with a mattress 100 nights that's three
months of your fat ass rolling around a
mattress killing it and if you don't
like it you send it back like a Savage
that you are no questions asked you foll
me send it back with your wife in it
that's right you have a 100 nights okay
that's why everybody from GQ Magazine
the Forbes all talking about Helix sleep
you go to helixsleep.com right now this
is what I'm going to do/ Joey and I'm
going to give you $50 off your order
that's helixsleep.com
Joey and that's $50 off your first order
helixsleep.com
joeey listen to me if you like sleeping
this is the matches for you cut this
who you lying to who you think
you're talking to Joey bananas here
number two here's the best one you got
smart cars you got smart phones you got
Smart Homes Technology has made
everything smart but losing your stuff
still makes smart people feel stupid
Dean Del said for the first time in his
life he lost his keys yesterday for 45
minutes I told him the same thing I'm
telling you people right tracker makes
losing things a thing of the past
tracker is a coin siiz device that
locates misplaced Keys wallets bags
computers anything in seconds just PIR
tracker to your smartphone attach it to
anything and find its precise location
within the to of a button it's that easy
you lose your phone no problem press the
button on tracker and your phone rings
listen to this even if it's on silent
who's better than you that's what
tracker does you got uh with over 1.5
million devices tracker has the largest
crowd GPS Network in the world so your
lost item shows up on a map even if it's
miles away you're never going to lose
anything away again with tracker
listeners to the show you ready for this
what I'm doing for you bam I'm going to
give give you 30% off your entire order
go to the the th H tracker.com and at
the promo code Church chur CH the
hardest thing you'll ever have to find
is their website but do me a favor again
go to
tracker.com now the
tracker.com right now and at the promo
code church for 30% off your entire
order again that's the
tracker.com promo code Church ch ch Who
the hell's better than you people again
the tracker.com right now into promo
code Church 30% off your order that's
how we make it happen here at the church
and what's happening now and never but
never forget hit.com cuz you know
without on it I wouldn't be here
right now I'd be without the
Alpha Brain cycle I do without my hemp
Force protein you on steroids or no no
look at me I'm a fat what steroids
if I was on steroids I'd have muscles
I'd be choking him right now i' be
helping him out right now got him the
Lord got I didn't know though
you know you look strong dog I got
no muscle could be could be musle
fat loose musle I got itches
over here I got a rash under my armpit
that's killing me and put a diaper
on it that now I'm getting all
itchy from the mushrooms and there
was some cyoptics and this
poor Bast you might as well one right
now and put track on your ass all the
cuz God knows where they're going to
take you I'm going lose you for sure I
know you got a trulance bro no let's not
call let's one of those Mexican
ambulances down the corner they'll take
it to a nice they'll take you whever
$150 they jerk you off and they'll jerk
you
off that's the type of people that my
man I know a girl for $360 dude will
treat you right for 24 hours
beautiful woman 360 there you go look at
look he's falling asleep anyway that's
why the problem with this mamuk
is he don't take shroom Tech Sport and
he don't take shroom Tech immune he's a
moo anyway do me a favor go to
onet.com right now and pressing the code
hit it church church what how do you
spell it C you C there you go boom and
you get 10% off you order delivered
right to your house man don't play
around listen honor is the way to go I
wouldn't blow smoke up your ass it's a
great you sure you're hot look
he's taking his shirt off like this is a
muscle kind no I'm H by the way you're
saying Who Am my on steroids look at me
I'm a fat cheeseburger went bad and
muscle this ain't muscle you just
made me scratch my arm I'm pulling my
shirt up if I had muscles I wouldn't
have sleeves anyway again
tracker.com right now I want to thank
heix sleep I want to thank an it I want
to thank my main man Theo van for coming
on and saying these
we're going to eat a shroom and that's
how we do here man that's what the
people died for us that's right it's
Wednesday night the church
Studios we love you stay
black see you Sunday night for a special
La Memorial Day little addition of the
church just to break the monotony up
Monday morning I love that bro see you
Muppets in the mud put the music
on Lee come on put it on W up Lee let's
do this Church us out you do this
the quicker we get a oh
listen to this
the I'm getting all scratchy from the
mushroom now no bro that sh it's
like eating three Vikings now I'm
burping dog I burped in the
bathroom I don't know what was worse my
burp or my piss oh the worst is when you
trying to get a uh when you eating a
girl out and she start oh Jesus Christ
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
the
all
[Applause]
[Music]